christine lagarde is the first woman to
be managing director of the
International Monetary Fund her
organization is an economic advisor and
occasional lender to nearly 200
countries Lagarde took office in 2011
when the global economy was recovering
from the financial crisis the IMF was
also shaken by questions about its own
governance Forbes routinely ranks
Lagarde among the 10 top most powerful
women in the world she was elected last
year to a second five-year term we
welcome her back to the table good
morning good morning it's good to have
you in New York lovely to be here where
the UN is meeting and we heard yesterday
from President of the United States
Donald Trump how would you characterize
the speech you know I'm not particularly
interested in rhetoric and I'm far more
interested in the realities and what I
heard yesterday about North Korea in
particular had a lot to do with politics
and rhetorics I was in Korea last week
and I could see for myself
you know how complex these issues are
and how critically important it is for
the South Koreans who live just across
the border and within range of whatever
could be done across the line of
demarkation so I think that those issues
are so difficult complicated that they
require a lot of goodwill a lot of calm
and a lot of cooperation and that's
where I think that yeah you know
rhetoric does not necessarily have an
interesting example the president did
suggest you know that the UN and the
Security Council had had a series of
approvals of sanctions where the UN was
acting as it should absolutely and and
clearly the vote that rallied all
members of the Security Council in order
to reinforce the sanctions was a
historical vote and clearly one that is
bringing the leaders and the countries
together with a view to eliminating this
this massive threat and this uncertainty
around so that is exactly the right
direction and it needs to be pursued and
sanctions you know economic sanctions
have proven to be efficient they need to
be implemented they need to be enforced
that's where you know it gets difficult
because the issue of finding out whether
shipments go where the ships are
registered whether Pyongyang is actually
getting some supply or not is something
that requires international cooperation
and sometimes reinventing the rules as
Charlie said you are one of the most
powerful women in the world someone else
who is labeled as one of the most
powerful woman in the world is Ivanka
Trump there for no other reason that she
has her father's ear there was a bit of
a pushback given her presence and the
Women's Forum in Germany along stage
with you also at the g20 sitting in for
her father it's something who has really
taken pride in meritocracy and stressed
the importance of meritocracy you
yourself what was your take and Ivanka
participating in these events and do you
think she earned a right at these seats
you know she's focusing from what I
understand on women issues empowering
women making sure that women
entrepreneurs from around the world can
have access to finance can be empowered
I think it is such a vital cause and
such a way to try to boost growth to
reduce inequalities to diversify
economies and to enable women to achieve
their potential that whatever lots of
other things that can be debated the
intention if it is delivered upon it's
critically important well you I work I
welcome that involvement how are you in
fact upset though women's empowerment
could be a game changer yes and it's a
no brainer charlie it's a no brainer
women can just bring so much in terms of
economic growth in terms of profit to
companies in terms of common sense in
risk-taking policies I think it's it's
criminal not to rely on women more than
we do so and I will continue pushing
that cause good common sense it could be
against that like the common sense and
we're 50% of the population yes so there
should be more women involved actually
and I absolutely agree with you
so what is your relationship like with
the administration he has made it very
clear during the campaign certainly that
he was not a supporter of the IMF what's
your relationship with his
administration you know my point of
contact is the Secretary of Treasury and
very early on
I had meetings with secretary Minuten we
had good meetings good discussions he
was preparing for the g7 and then for
the g20 and we contributed to I think
bringing up bringing him up to speed on
certain issues that we focus on on the
issue of progress with this
administration you know there's
something that we do with every member
we review the economy of each country
and we make recommendations we certainly
have made recommendations concerning tax
and the tax reform the first draft and
I'm not going to comment on the depth of
the draft because I haven't seen it but
the tax reform in its principles we
support it and we are prepared to
continue to examine and explore and make
recommendations to boost growth to
create jobs but it's our income class to
middle-class income but you lured your
estimate for us see yes we growth that's
2.1 percent yes we did what sure well
around 2.1 might be a little little
higher than that but we did because
there was there were very strong market
expectations early in the calendar year
after the elections that the tax reform
would take place promptly that massive
investment would be made in
infrastructure and that there would be a
push
it hasn't happened it doesn't
materialize at all so that's the reason
why we lowered out so you think will be
very difficult for the administration to
be able to meet its own goal of 3 to 4
percent economic growth we think it's
going to be very difficult yes
particularly if the the reform pace is
as slow as it is yeah and that contrast
with the rest of the world because the
rest of the world is doing pretty China
7% we have a six point eight percent
forecast for China and Europe is picking
up now and gaining momentum so the
overall growth in the world is is pretty
uh pretty pretty good well if the
president is watching I'm sure we'll see
a tweet that quoting you saying that we
need to focus on tax reform here and
infrastructure and getting things done
I'm sure he's yes jinx stalling in
Washington christine lagarde thank you
so much for joining us